what no bs screenwriting advice can you
give to
young screenwriters or even older who've
never sold something
and think that they can make a living at
this well you got to really be realistic
you have to look at the steps
involved if and what is your uh
end game you know do you want to get a
movie made it's a small movie what kind
of movie is it are you writing a
kind of studio type script are you
writing kind of a you know
a small intimate thing that we made for
you know half a million dollars
so you have to kind of set the
parameters of what you want to do
you know and kind of take it from there
because if you're a young screenwriter
and you want to do this for a living
i mean you need to write a couple
samples and write some scripts you know
you need to be around the film business
you know tv has given a lot of
opportunities to you know
being on writing staff there's so many
tv shows now too that's a great way to
becoming writers you can become a
writer's assistant
get to know the the working writers you
know and you'll actually get paid taking
notes doing things and learn how it all
works and that that will help you with
jobs if you're a little bit older
i mean you should really work on you
know work on your screenplays but
also determine what do you want to do is
it something that you want to try to get
made on your own do you want to try you
know
like it's a little bit different are you
writing a john wick movie or are you
writing a
you know small intimate thing because if
it's john wick movie
that means you have to sell it through
the studio system that's
very hard to break into until you like
are working at a certain level
it does happen but you usually have to
work your way up you don't just
you know all of a sudden you're not up
for like these gigantic jobs of writing
you know 100 million dollar films
so that's that's a whole kind of skill
set into itself
so my advice would be just just keep
working but work on your craft because
people don't do that they don't you know
they don't take the time to actually
keep rewriting and learning to write
you know they write one thing and they
think here it is world
you know and that that's why it doesn't
get made and then they get frustrated
but i think anybody who's going to take
if you're determined
and you want to take you know 10 years
of your life
working super hard to get somewhere you
can get somewhere
you get some movies made you can you can
do it for a living but you have to
really like
buckle down and be like okay am i going
to like
save enough money for a year that's kind
of what i did i'm just going to save
enough money so i don't have to work for
your focus on this
or just really you know and being in la
is a big part of it too
it really is you know unfortunately it's
like it's hard to become
you know a professional screenwriter
when you're in missouri or somewhere
because a lot of the connections you
make and people you meet
you know i ran into a friend of mine
who's a big producer
at the coffee bean one day i hadn't seen
her a while and she said
what are you working on i go well we got
this zombie thing and she goes oh call
me later and then we got paid to write
it for
for a huge company so it's like but
those are
relationships i've developed for a long
time but if i wasn't in la i wouldn't
ran into her
you know it's it's these are just things
that you know happen
and you know so it's that's another part
of it too
so you have to be in the gate you have
to be around it you can't just
you know be outside of it because
there's a lot to learn a lot of people
to meet it's all about relationships too
what year was this that you had saved up
the money so that you could live for a
year
i think it was 2005. oh okay so the
economy was doing well
so yeah i produced i produced a movie
with david boreanas
and then i did a big music video and
and got paid well on both those so it's
like okay now's the time
so um yeah because i didn't want to keep
producing films because producing's
producing is fun i like producing but
it's different it's not that creative
so i was just like now's the time so
what i did is i just planned for a whole
year it's like okay i'm just gonna focus
on this and it worked but
i'd worked around i'd been in the
business and worked in the business and
knew people so it wasn't
you know coming out from somewhere
moving to l.a and a small apartment just
going okay i got a year to make it but
you know if you want to do it you can do
it it's not the good thing about
screenwriting it doesn't take a ton of
money to do it
you don't it's i mean if you want to
make a short film that
you have to hire a crew you have to
shoot you know to write you know even
the other day a really
big a-list director not to say it was he
goes writing's free
you know if you want to just sit and
write and do as many drafts you want you
it's your time but it doesn't cost you
anything
so day one of that like we're doing this
i'm not you know i'm not taking any new
commitments on what was your did you
like schedule things out did you have it
on a calendar today no i wish i was that
i wish i was that organized it was a lot
of intuition just like okay now feels
like the time
you know so no it wasn't i wish it was
more planned out but you know
sometimes you know some of this stuff
just happens but you have to be in the
game for it to happen
you know i put myself in the situation
where it's like okay this is all i'm
gonna do and just talk to people about
it
you know annoyed agents that i knew i
was like hey i wrote this script i'm
working on the script and they didn't
care you know even though i knew them
you know they're like great good luck
but i was like okay this is the time now
to be really focused
on on just and not really having a plan
b
and how many hours a day did you write
during that year
probably like three or four but i think
after
four hours you get a little bit like
diminished returns now that doesn't mean
the other
five or six hours a day i'm not thinking
about the writing
like but physically sitting there behind
the keyboard
usually you try to limit to like four
hours because after four hours you start
getting
if the work starts getting a little like
you know not there
you know you're not sharp why keep
writing but i'm always thinking about
things like a lot of things when i write
i don't touch keyboard until i figured
out the whole for like i said the whole
first act
the second act turn and i will i can sit
down one day and write 20 pages
but i've thought about it for two or
three weeks and maybe just wrote out and
beats what's going to happen
and then you know it's not the best 20
pages in the world but i can do it one
day
in a couple hours but i know where
everything's going to fit and what the
beats are and then i'll go back and
rewrite the dialogue and rework the
scenes but
i know it's going to happen so after a
year did you
say okay time to start making money
again
or you it just naturally progressed it
started happening
oh okay yeah so got lucky in that sense
very nice and then that film you ended
up selling it
yeah the second the second script we
wrote second script oh yeah
yeah that was the one that didn't get
made but yeah i got paid for that
and that was a nice that was a good
feeling i would think that was the first
time i ever got paid to be creative you
know i've been i've worked on films but
that's a little bit different kind of
creativity you know as being a producer
but being creative it was it's like the
greatest feeling in the world to like
do something creative and get paid well
for it you're like what this
actually you can actually do this and
that's a that's a big inspiration once
you get that once it becomes kind of a
rush it's like
oh hey this is better than working at
starbucks not that i have work to start
but you know or you know going to an
office
yeah much better than going to an office
yeah
did you have office jobs no i mean in
the film industry i did
i always i was very lucky i just but i
always kind of angled myself to where i
had a cool job because i
didn't want to be bored at work that was
like the only
mantra i had was like i don't want to be
bored
you